said I wish you can all gb per week
you already learn I can iron myself
necrophilia color
the this could like this
yes that fikkert nl stuck content ok so is
bed race
oak is for whom it fell faster
he would already introduce it gnome
Deurningen  traffic and free kids
interesting for two reasons
the personal is pico's have you for
such a learning who even so every country or
print icon use cases get
moses to row for dilution
mission ar in games sorry for
grande games like a go for some purchase
or notari games en de second reason is
that reason for thoughtdeurningen
intraffic is particularly interesting
inspi opportunities
problem all fixed hot standing in
traffic jams and waiting for a green
light at an interview with my death
note 3 lite dave and then she was
hopefully weekenden does  something about
their with do you mean durning
and al take you take you on a journey so
quick introduction
then i wanna talk about a week for
social learnin  g motionless what who you for
about 13 first green ok i would be
wider than the people who is xlii then you
can wording but coding and make
now is
ok if smaller already would how i
see your nose what james is in the bio force
learning context will also people to teach
van ved een dat at the end of the
sectional like to everybody quinoa dj
miss en hou you can do reinforcement
learning first de water company is
between small consultancy for the people
this was a trip to malaga streak het die
opportunities for 5 year anniversary
being an independent company
who had this goal since 2000 line and
who here i do a ladder the community
city so far speaking at conferences with
well so organ asiëlaan or
conferences we land more tips video open
source contributions so if you'  re in the
netherlands' doe en in hampstead en er
ja doe check out if i had some other
event rest om afrika get something and
his head and man or the consultant he can
judge me for himself site i  s alwijs well
since a month and i can be myself there
detailer african well the set
many of the this site is not
poorer
with Merkel the sewing and that this beautiful
businesslike as oh yes i s mary oh god
i think you that this on  wit
who look already who can you anyway a
patient idols and was a remake sense
with the effect is when
help people who like it
lk feedback because leather is for neil
sadick my current clients
is hairdresser in the traffic the mee to
space
the right image already  the hardware around us
intersections will never
look physical dataction and die the delights i
yukhow you now we know of light and all
the other hardware and well the most beautiful
hardware would be trying to focus
more our clever software
kas of the hardware firmware the user's
of the clever control great if you
delete the long waiting time in this
section and they also the of any other
topic as these days dizzy of a beauty
king of the wander I myself have driving
cars slightly karres k  an the beer crates
stay isense horsecollar all tools en
in the preacher
a traffic controller at en intersection
will be able to support cars van age i
hate halloumi so ow and dat the site
ok but i can keep i this cooliris
car harder any other vehicles that not
the priority for shampoo pass with for
the people you then the step and then
powder border castellane of missions
youtube it as a all people waiting
maybe 1000 ad balance please do
something i wonder if the priority and the
door checks can be a week if the
sitchin's to himself and other tink the
intention and tight flat tuning so she has
there she will soon be in euros
you live he kieftenbeld greenlight in your
then van toe category light into
wedgelike hi therefore very interesting
stuff you like you like
so you have pilav kristal can
hiring there  toe and there as hef
king of coding scavengers in eastern
europe
me be interesting des point and two
domains
all the talking outside the mobile 10 him
e  and would outside reinforcement learning
many efftink almost everybody here in the
sun was the further where
from the that my projector go to be able
to bed offers best go player
who offers you advantages in the best chess
player long time ago texelse bit more
tricky game  but there is also more easy
for a journey every key coming
interplay
and then into all their practical area
social oil bath games and the more i see
for some more that is being used in
server
space a server racks due to keep the
temperature constant and then it  is
maybe would popping horne pop i have
this ladder controls to the tweak the
temperature and proceeded to you for
sharing our items can be applied in box
can the settings to as hard as a work
basically who you for sharing is widia
simple gays stupidly simple
will  you just ran a simple and there are
agents that he each want the nest make
decisions about what to do for you i
am the game over chess game with which
kpi's too tired for
what  ch movies how relaxed is acting in a
violent would the box and rules of the
game would the game or the chess game
it who she always so true all those
positions you put here
her way white star rider
hdtv hd underboard and these tags and  b
sonnet always and the extreme high five
and chili
were able to win the game and I really think it's
the game of war rhino the the actions
that were sign
were good and the fury tricky game that
we well that the motion plastic access the
way to  left to all was something like it ca
n't pan is like you can other penalty
about your doctor depending on
subjects you would do the number so
the simple look is that evergreen terrace
and if you train that blood long enough
and you she lag computer then the adi  is
that the computer will therefore euro and
that also white mine and it you
be able to eventually play bad en and
human could be kas de adi you are there the
boys count
well thus posible states and other
possible options in the code re  d kfc
backgammon gaslight and then that younger
order or trendy bossche bol always smoke
oh dear dear quasir that's
how hymer camp now the
glasses get rid of it and resources
who would a strong learning thing
stable working in the sky or
simple environments  where so large
always space
sander is so place in finish the many
options de the dress and that comprehend and
leaning there now for them
could be able to learn something a few
and simulation many books if you let
jane hey beda
and the age elite center work  and it doesn't
disappoint an anointing about time
and then I'm so proud of you able to achieve
so the superhuman experience is
so true who you imagine learning
technology is staying in the hype cycle was
begining
and think this year euro audience
dies here's some where people you  were
baerenthal the time specific as if
type mind and we see that the cause
there's a lot of open source frameworks
being mobile is nice to have a monthly
and so the longer it  income from in
the community round is
review singing in this x number of cuirass and
die open edge in
zo wit in treffik brubeck looking
looking back at the magnifying glass and zo lets
imagine instead of the go bord
teacher the intersection twist and
intersection het heft to actions  in this
case lighter you can deer north and
south light green or you can have something in
the west liteon green
kind of jester choose between above the
third ever of the interstage hobby
how many cars and waiting in
soft accuse for something of delights hello
gives the leg  waiting all ready
hello was it red light or any other
cars on rising
over time what can you or kanger sara caught
death i could
still that you care and you can imagine
that euro that looks like to me now tions
force if you intersection  poor who
think that is bout
but you can the goal is to make it thicker
skill engineer lab coat managing a
single intersection
what you can and look at and network of
intersections elephant cup like
senio  r be there like this
simulation about hire
dickerson fill maximizing the
the flow of hit i encountered network
it will be in foil complex simulations
and tweaking of all the parameters
he hopes at this time you understand
it as the boy so far your hard to
optimize so  in the perfect setting and
how you a big early age i could it ate
you him from his so so where your traffic
is out left good case for you big
my learning and i'm ready x-play
shares bilbao sections and that always
that you  that you meet him designing your
actions about and this is the expert me that
we joest and the simple that we use for
this project
it in i all these tests of new
control
control agents of software under simple
scenarios and this is a simple
intersection
and designer  for actions you can ai the
production
light green that was that when this long
such a each of the directions
think of all that multicul to grow is just
the sametime between very easy basics
scenario nfi soft  true the news about of
the no sable applies the scenario then do
be more scenario testing right through
this so the first set is finished and in
benefits scenario
you can chase your but or kars queen
for miss darcy so
the scenario we are here in testing for
in the first case what I already have one two
tree for meaning follower casper our
of this
direction to the of the direction vibrating
of leather machine in advance for with
direction
xlii shifts but one so when access
it rianne to form air and so there is
a  call a scenario like
arabia full of learning edge it for
this scenario should be able to learn
that is probably very nice green
tour die to the lower louis terrasje
anyway so ff the chasing the seat of
course make em how you so who of the
etten-leur mike want ferrari
the cards to your
iphone from the friend moment cissé times
are to be able to tune generalized a
little bit more and then the idea is to
to to  test dummy scenarios for xaphok
be used for van after four
directions des for van karssen
coaching brewer
s there is a maximum capacity headset
is for that mean intersection so
is that also towards sable sky the
domino the the helm the sexy this
for controlling'  that in the section
and the for be actually
start trainings om de force one and
the others oui oui tak tests by
agents
om a levels impressario and that's
just for a net cars for one direction
a kind not funny had treat their
actions and what should read  for sharing
learn and that situation and should be
able to learn to cook that light om
green al de tuin van der weg we are
super simple what you can do now is kan
of testing to make sure that you
actually see that i one so learning
and  working at the for you so more
complicated substance than half special
and interpret in the de finds two
parameters or so
when looking at a durning het actual
ver  y very very long time already there is
here so the keyboard 5 million step
stitches and ar each garden takes about 2 your
ancestors for then million steps
so this is like to this training for
just one model and hiver parameters and you
see an uneven finish  and manner of
mosul time just sitting and after that is
in eg and hospital the training
going out there meta has upgrade to
the divisors if you will you
rieti that is then also discovered by it is
why i killed lydians way how do
you hefty learning  and practice what you
can do with you can ever renner maud
for for the games your play and you can
see what the ages do it their
particular moment in time
zo'n you can understand what scorion and
what itslearning
so wie ff this is this is  one of those jim
beige moments when i was expecting and
cables are coming what what you characters
happening in this so in this case
sequence interview it is about nutrition
museum what is it about fitting in
who said
yes h  et is here always book about fitting
because it oil passions die they
yes so the one the drag in this case this
direction hesse the motor cars per hour
something so color taupe paul green
old-time and the people purdy test score
rest and are care of  local if we
win then because those men who
thankfully put it in what they have
so appreciate you for shell durning there is
a furry performance of between
exploitation and exploration and in this
case
who is exploit in the lan that we know
that there is  more kars kom i found
only salt
but we need to explore the two in order
to find that we also have put this order
complete circuit can this is a party
who is what coaching the simulation to go
game about
henrique all the game about winners tour
die  car-secure up or wear or when one
carnage to wait for more than two
minutes
it is always desirable scenario
to lift someone in your practice so the region that
pan is in rep en and hopefully the cult
of the e  xploration and certain point
europe cup oh damn it's not there a
switch
the greenlight one that already somewhere so
here door just
and behind tripoli six million steps for
shopping
and then you see the in this case mino that
that wrap maximum score it know her
for this  game is never in hang by
solving and we've got the agents inside
able to togethere
togethere  percent exploration
would it is that creasing is my
expiration for one half percent so
tempers and
knightley not early and dennis do it
en percent and this it about four million
steps
so at this point it was i will still
sporing for temper cent in this this
part
have who after almost how you of that
optimal policy for this expert with
people this is what you how much i want your
cursor look resemble
toads takes time right greenhouses in this
case vfc
six  million steps them off the two this
mini unit was can they had how your goal
is the track that easy
first in you not the hips are similar
there procession traffic siebe leaders
bosschebollen so domain the one is the
fishing we no longer use how it  is a
commercial package
the other one superb simulations
in sumo is open source and is open source
choose now we already prefer this one what
things i is using an offer and alice is
an external die volt i became serius to
vis him so for business creatures we  it
better use case m so then be deleted
coffins the business or the smart leather
that you like he also ritthem shadows
begins the third year but one of the the
anointing for is fish him ken oil
or long white goopy anyway startup the
de defuse already  the timer think loge
clear him and stang in that tastes
like for science and closing clear
it's fun for slack and them in each of
the episodes free during the light
thousands of episodes
wheels a secans all  time for fire
i had a new person so that read
the training lot
and another lonely build things windows
winner of lag motionless
is that it is the tennessee to do we the
as auto update
and then the chance also daddy and
effect were absent it  self tucked in thickest
point would you do viewers i became i have
your cheeks pushed itself
over definitions for so on you what who
served too expensive that
was too in take over control of the similar
cabinets sim bradley sim'lar so wants to
of the tour die  less simulation time
which defines one app so what we need to
good in
easystep peach is sector half second
you don't tick anymore
chicken work the states from van de vis in
the states
who not to give back to the agents the
age the nothing it  youth in action
the action and services be given back to
the simpler and simpler carolina step
and think it back the increasingly ambitious
none en des doigts re wie voor of
look chewing gum on german episode
youth training
and the doe rec  ap muse blocking views to
make sure that this symbol leader fishing
is waiting for new action in the cue
toe start running the next i would almost
committed all garden so this is the who
gives the agents
control over the chimu army in mortality
limburger over the agents  my who
to see this technical bed in and so if there
are episodes fishing mash up down for
some point post game over
take him access door that minus
simulation garden must be successful and a
new vision is starre that in an extra
sauce such  good start things that their
training done on the garden and the way you
you you you the bump all this is this is
called an environment
and this is the promise good frame wars use
administrator you for such an hour the face
openness and i opened it  his
website love free build and
vitamins for sabel for games like carpal
where you have the balance a car apollon
under card and it has to stay in balance
and it falls down
yes i had there penalty and you can put a
word for it  time it stays at
en de area for learning hester app has
to learn to keep
and you can paste in
your own agents and see if you can you
can learn faster than the ducks in
there already surinaams en catcher me
disappoint you for such learning
and ass big a de steller it would if
you are able to build  sheriff arms like
this
ben you can paste in any of the jade
agents de smart agency.com and
door we john harmon sorry if you said it
up this way you'll be you be good to go
and do that is woozo here is you pray
coat voor je die is bizarre i samos to
warm up saturday already like young people
optimized roman
ping pong where ever you can you get
die experience from there but they all look
like this
and this is how you had to build your
own environment and their function and
de  step is
execu get estate then  his action
executed action and get there your heart like
the magnifying glass that went along again all time and
then the reset is what happens between the
episodes zo
when will you got game over picasso van
longview of cars hot merchants die
episodes
who can who they who  and fire with a
start in your game for some progress is
also you won there tricky game that can
reset port player new
and then there's another van sjaak as a
rider and so this just to visualize
your not what a simple and efficient is
allwise puzzle leader socializing  them for
if they dmx controllable 20 mentor zo de
lodge I rush you into these two
functions and
and then you can run and diet you of
trap so that it very easy to build your
own environment at setting and start
playing in a chance of reinforcement
learning agents
so this is the yim part of if the tidal of
with talk to grab it up a bit more
learning takes the lid long time
it intuitive videos and it becomes
more tea is my dress va  n you want to
optimize your area for its learning from
you a chauffeur salon of choices right
make and like it can take 2 days
before you know if any kind of a
training session was successful astrid
would have you late using cheat machines
and the problem using
super machine you feel here take rather
longer what kind of fox i'll be left to
choose the game
re door the entire with can you of the
scenario at home different ways with you
you can code up and then durst this
thing de riwayaah hack you canary
warger  agents to give good greenlight
om of subspecies intersection and so
many choices
full champoluc ac ok for each time is
this like it one one ruard a dislike
carpool the long zipper this live de barry
that's it's called such a couple is not durning
review do  between the tour to minimize
the
cues of of each of the satellite zo'n you
could also say ok to maybury war
depending on the mountain view of the
car securing up and then je kc ok bye
what ik de  chicken the big penalty rush cabbage
game over
do me because I win the big bonus is
complete the ladder choices and each time
you make another of the three why choose
your age it is can a learn something
els or something different
and you can that will come  another setting
positive and three quarters
so de zo des des already het of joyce
then you have to say what what the
information that a huis de act upon
carson recited if you would wish
light is to how you
do it what means also count it  carla
driving of the shirt interactions
that this is already so ardie hart choice
and then you can choose a love agents to
me that that stuff and teach of so
agents
of the
agents then I would youtube and tesco machine
learning and you get used to forest and
you want to high parameters
tuning it in your already wild creatures
hi-tec ok bridgehead shapes so die
want you give assumptions is k  an er
undead and medias with this finish line
notion or village spaces
what might be something on the twin sisters
in this case the cash register streetdance
high power led what can be the active fit
random search for especially
shape land and if there is a land come
back to this look  at the closet or my
computer about cloth more countries of
money to find it
who has it right it is built in
more more carefully and thinks that you
can you can talk ball is lek the
exploration policy
aw total little bit about that there's
the the the  higher you can explore news
and then the memory size ah many past
observations always an action press this
can choose from van learning de niet
regent en de new action zo
en dear site of that you can also use
all kinds of violet rook architecture
for your age  and to learn and which action
is best a white china rio en
and who van force answers
lifeboat out readers
helps to for the age the public can me
more more strong and tomorrow and the les
folles it  well
already the training i chose study
so it's a touch up and tissue
lifetime so be a few can do portia
learning is still getting hard
so this the dashboard is a nice thing
no sharpening suede had to do for such a
budget  himself
check out this series of blogpost
is effective family good slim and lined
infant blocks and the visuals
explaining how for this are early works
and for sauber the magnifying glass with al would the
dissertations like you we the deep wine
network or the de troubled ritual is al
x  -play trudy well in there you would features
three box then quite a lot you're like
had so python 3 strong learning is
joanna blythe entry a considerable journey
into some cases drugs per met you there
yourself checkout boxes and fire mens in the
gin is already  such a whole land of explanation
of how to build your own gin and then if
you wanna do it in tref ik dit is not
my god had ons grafic
picasso be built for clients and mikuni
shared wat's wat wiet min is het
photomodel smooth in  h  et ons um die open
source traffic simpler and all other
things that i built in this and
parliament
who is war used as a base is for
parents would it is for f' and t' you
love the gyms a very similar
and there is with this  knowledge i should
be able to get the same things
go and running  lug
to tank
the commission and warsaw for experience
like here a
grandpa of you very good time that the checkmark
for the branch
downloaded the photos great power supplies
itself there no longer use
corstjens depressions
yes it is one of brush functional in
for you will there  a joint
even at the bottom like a hear the bun
with the mind
update i hear you feel there is' or steven
actions are
right aik alim extra
digitalist or stone who put a tip down and
latino reinforcement learning sensor is now
way with the digist  rether's
yes so who we just aren't you sing
dick your and with it such a simple cure
learning
have the door network and then who expert
with it with
during the commence to get more stable
but we haven't tried technology would there
here so see that is does it
maybe it
the that double peak in das hill at
mars teddy
training would it is so in that sense
mountain but it takes seems to reset long ago
numbers
the steller to learning with it
as it's also quieter  journey to fly
it is best that agents and learning with
is for this purpose
surprise
menu to do a job high tide here left for involved just enough to just economic eady's live
summer so can favorite genres in the
world for traffic control or is this
just
experiment of  so the island and not sure
if it's already used in real traffic
scenarios in the cave the guy he is
discreet ab east his american by
apis that guys and scuttle anne fork
and videos on internet is about  would this
copies here drugs or in america that out
or eating or but yet but in the in
the dutch context
again expert menting and we this and
primark i like your detail it around the
single intersection the lens first like
and isolated warming ski transports a
little wannabe server that actually
performs well as its traffic and the
fairy cloves it queso i don't know
any there is yet but it will you for
smooth testing before i pudding the
trick he has a hefty my shirt
rock4 posies
[Applause]